حيوانات حيوانات بين الناس وفي الغابات
تعطي جمالا للحياة يال جمال الكائنات
ثَعْلَبْ وَأُكَنَّى ثَعْلُوبْ  *** خَدَّاعٌ دَوْمًا وَلَعُوبْ
مَكَّارٌ لَقَبِي المَشْهُورْ ***  فِي الغَالِبِ أَرْجِعُ مَغْلُوبْ
فِي الغَالِبِ أَرْجِعُ مَغْلُوبْ
فِي عِزٍّ أَمْشِي وَشَهَامَةْ   ***  نَمِرٌ جِسْمِي فِيهِ ضَخَامَةْ
كَالقِطَّةِ لَكِنِّي أَكْبَرْ *** وَخُطُوطِي السَّوْدَاءُ عَلَامَةْ
وَخُطُوطِي السَّوْدَاءُ عَلَامَةْ
بِرَأْسِي قَرْنٌ مَيَّزَنِي  ***   ضَخْمٌ مَا أَكْبَرَ وَزْنِي
لَوْنِي رَمَادِيٌّ جَمِيلْ ***   سَمُّونِي وَحِيدَ القَرْنِ
سَمُّونِي وَحِيدَ القَرْنِ
حيوانات حيوانات بين الناس وفي الغابات
تعطي جمالا للحياة يال جمال الكائنات
لِي جِلْدٌ ضَخْمٌ وَحَرَاشِفْ ***   سَبَّاحٌ أَيْضًا أَنَا زَاحِفْ
أُنْظُرُوا مَا أَكْبَرَ فَكَّيْ ***    تِمْسَاحٌ لِي دَمْعٌ زَائِفْ
تِمْسَاحٌ لِي دَمْعٌ زَائِفْ
طَيِّبَةُ القَلْبِ وَوَدِيعَةْ ***    فَاتِنَةُ المَظْهَرِ وَمُطِيعَةْ
لِي قَرْنَانِ أُسَمَّى غَزَالَةْ  ***    بِالْجَرْيِ أَنَا جِدَّ سَرِيعَةْ
بِالْجَرْيِ أَنَا جِدَّ سَرِيعَةْ
أَنَا فَرَسُ النَّهْرِ أَلَمْ تَعْلَمْ ***    بَيْنَ الحَيَوَانَاتِ الأَضْخَمْ
فِي اليَابِسَةِ أَقْضِي وَقْتِي ***    أَوْ فِي النَّهْرِ أَنَا أَسْتَحْمِمْ
أَوْ فِي النَّهْرِ أَنَا أَسْتَحْمِمْ
حيوانات حيوانات بين الناس وفي الغابات
تعطي جمالا للحياة يال جمال الكائنات